President Biden's expected to announce a
new package of military aid for Kiev it
will likely contain what one U.S
official called a very important new
capability namely a patriot missile
defense system
that could help Ukraine better defend
itself against Russian attacks
but training Personnel on how to use the
missiles properly could take as long as
six weeks
and I'm very pleased to welcome Marina
Myron from the defense studies
department at King's College London for
more on this story Marina Patriot
missiles could soon be headed for
Ukraine do you think they would make a
serious difference in this war
thank you for having me so yes
absolutely uh first of all we have to
consider that this is the most
sophisticated system that is being
promised to Ukraine So in theory Patrick
missile systems could make a difference
however we have to remember that they
will not be deployed immediately and
that training has to take place or has
been an arrangement to train Ukrainian
troops in Germany to operate those
systems so the big question is what will
happen on the battlefield until the
systems arrive will they be able to
arrive on time to save the Ukrainian
power grid so that's basically the main
problem and also as zolensky and general
solution have pointed out it's not
enough so they want long-range missiles
which the United States doesn't want to
provide so in how far just Patriot
systems alone will be able to change the
course of the war remains questionable
so there's this question of timing
that's crucial there's of course also
been talk of Russia preparing another
major offensive possibly even with help
from Belarus do you think that that is
realistic given months of Russian
setbacks on the battlefield
indeed there have been signs
um basically putting meeting lukashenka
and discussing these matters behind
closed doors and then signing um
military cooperation on December 3rd the
document is not disclosed so there is a
lot of secrecy behind it obviously this
is all being reported by Western media
which Russia wants in order to sought
doubt in order to
basically make this threat credible but
Belarus doesn't seem to want to be
involved in the war and as a matter of
fact there is a lot of opposition and a
lot of citizens have gone to Ukraine to
join the Ukrainian military so for
lukashenko it will be very difficult to
create some kind of a balance because
Belarus is dependent on Russia on the
one hand and it's training Russian
troops as we speak and on the other hand
it has this um
popular opposition to any involvement so
um perhaps Belarus will not enter the
war as an additional actor but what it
could do is provide a launch platform
for Russia to launch its offensive
however
um as the Kremlin spokesman said Dmitry
peskov he neither confirmed nor denied
the fact that there will be a major
offensive kind of leaving us all
guessing and in the dark and it could be
a way to lure away Ukrainian troops and
to refocus on a different geographical
position while Russia is making or
trying to make gains in the donbas thank
you for that assessment Marina Before I
Let You Go I also want to ask you what
you think about President zielinski's
visit to the United States do you think
it's the right time for him to be making
this trip
well perhaps it's not the right time
given the chaos that is going on in
Ukraine however it is important to
counterbalance that you know put in
lukashenka meeting and the growing ties
between Putin and erdogan in light of
the Turkish election so for zelenski
it's important to secure the support of
the United States and especially because
there is some skepticism coming from the
Republicans
um as far as the aid is concerned and
they want to
um launch an audit or at least say
threaten to do so to see where is that
money and all the Weaponry is going and
what Ukraine is doing with that so
appearing there personally might help to
strengthen the ties and um show to the
International Community and specifically
to put in that the US is still standing
behind Ukraine and that U.S will be
supporting Ukraine because if Ukraine
were to lose
um the help of the United States Europe
combined wouldn't be able to make up for
that help both in terms of financial aid
and in terms of military aid so it's
very important to make sure that the
United States doesn't withdraw and of
course zelensky might plead to get more
advanced weapons so that the Ukrainian
forces can achieve the aims outlined by
zelenski um to push back the Russian
forces and to retake Crimea especially
important as it says amidst the
skepticism growing amongst European
leaders such as macron who is
considering that there is a venue for a
dialogue was put in okay the key role of
the United States we'll be keeping a
close eye on that meeting of course
thank you so much for joining us with
that update that's big Marina Myron
and meanwhile in a speech to his defense
Chiefs of Vladimir Putin has vowed that
Russia will achieve all of its goals in
Ukraine the Russian president told them
the military would receive whatever it
needed without Financial limits he
announced that the Russian Navy would be
equipped with new Hypersonic Cruise
muscles early next year who can also
stressed that Russia would continue to
develop its strategic nuclear forces and
the new sarmat intercontinental
ballistic missile would be ready for
deployment in the near future
Thompson I know
well a Vladimir Putin stress that the
Russian army would get everything it
needs to fight this war in Ukraine
everything a serviceman needs should be
modern comfortable and reliable and the
supply should be based on real needs
if some departmental standards are
outdated they need to be changed quickly
I would like to draw the attention of
the Minister of Defense the chief of the
general staff and all the commanders who
are represented here
we have no funding restrictions the
country the government give everything
that the Army asks for everything
I hope the answer will be appropriately
formulated and the corresponding results
will be achieved
so to help us understand all this I'd
like to bring in Roman goncharenko from
DW's Russian service in Bonn thanks so
much for taking the time we have Putin
inviting thousands of soldiers to then
only speak to them for a few minutes can
you tell us more about the message that
he was trying to get across
well um there was not much new in what
he said uh the central message was the
war in Ukraine will continue Russia is
not backing up Russia will um try to
persuade its goals in Ukraine which is
to
um uh control most of its territory
basically
um and um he also said um a few
interesting things uh anyway I think
um maybe one of the most interesting
things is that he acknowledged there
were problems with mobilization uh he
said that
um those problems should be
um uh shouldn't get bad as also the
problem should be solved he said that
there are enough uh forces that have
been mobilized 300 000 and he hinted the
um at the moment that's enough and it's
important because that mobilization is
not very popular in the Russian Society
he also promised the modernization of
the army as if you've just mentioned and
he said that there will be no Financial
limits so he basically said to his
soldiers and offices tell me what you
need and I will give it to you I will
give the money for that
um he also repeated his uh previous
remarks about
blaming the west and and seeing that the
Russia is not is not to blame for this
war he said it is it's a tragedy but we
were forced to act
um in and it struck me that he very
clearly said that he sees himself in a
kind of a better position than Ukraine
in the west because Russia has modern
weapons that other countries don't have
uh he very clearly stated that so he
thinks it was a good time the right time
for Usher to strike because Russia has
better weapons so it was very clear that
this is his thinking uh and um
he also said that uh what's interesting
was said not by President Putin but by
his defense minister Sega who said who
suggested to increase the Russian army
um and it should be um one and a half
million uh soldiers uh it is interesting
that uh President Putin already uh last
year um decided per degree to increase
the Russian army and it is supposed to
be uh just over 1 million uh starting in
January and now here comes one more uh
increase so that means that Russia is
having losses in this war in Ukraine and
those losses need to be compensated
okay thank you so much for bringing us
up to speed on that story that's Roman
contr